what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider interview Studio at Sundance
2024 brought to you by the fine folks at
filo filo is all about putting the power
to Greenlight films in the hands of fans
and creators and we are lucky to have
them behind us supporting us as we get
to cover independent film if you want to
learn more about filmo check out their
website
film. now I have the pleasure of
introducing you all to the team behind
10 lives huge congratulations on your
movie I'm a big cat lover this movie
filled my heart oh good man that's
lovely so Chris I'm going to throw this
first question to you because a lot of
our viewers are going to be first
learning about 10 lives via Sundance so
would you do them a favor and give them
a brief synopsis of your movie I give a
brief synopsis by pointing to be at you
who where we meet him at the beginning
of the movie is um he he's a cat that's
that thinks he's got humans down all
figured out and through the process of
being very selfish he loses Nine Lives
then he meets Rose and and and
understands oh there's something better
here I I don't want to be a Jer like I
was before but then her boyfriend comes
back into the picture and all bets are
off because doesn't want to live in a r
truck for the kids that three people are
living what um but uh and so he goes
about trying to get rid of Larry the
ex-boyfriend and in doing so he loses
his last his night life he goes up to
the the gateway to the other lives that
cats have and is eventually because of
his sincere love for Rose is offered
night Mo lives and it that's the best
thing it could possibly have happened
but he comes back all his different RS
and and so the story from there is about
how a cat uh is learning by being in
someone else's
shoes and and learning to not be selfish
and to appreciate life for what it gives
you cat human anything I feel like
everything on this planet would benefit
from learning like that that's a good
hope yes toart question about uh
developing this idea what was the very
first part of the story that you came up
with the thing that started it all but
then I also want to know did you have a
break story moment a thing that you came
up with along the way that made you
convinced you had a whole vision for
this tale well actually yeah I mean
there were many long way I mean when you
get to work with such incredible people
and uh we had a wonderful cast in
general and so what I like to do is to
create room for the actors to inhabit
the character and and not necessarily
follow the script um and it's in that
process of discovery improvisation
that you really start find about well
what would they do what would how does
Rose really feel about this how does
Beck really feel AC this how much of a
jerk at the beginning is he and how far
can we bring him back to a place where
ores can cheer and cry
or and um and and so that was a complete
Revelation all the way through it was it
was a beautiful project to work on the
the beginning of it for me was really
when I was uh told that I could sent
this in England and so we went to dorson
which is the English R
Rivier um all great animated movies like
to take you somewhere else Lion King
takes you to Africa obviously the
mermaid takes you to some um Under the
Sea Under the Sea thank you very much
and um and it was it was a wonderful
opportunity for me cuz I live in Las
Angeles to dive into everything I love
about
fand and make it as much of a character
as the characters are so nothing was
disingenuous about the movie everything
was sincere and that's what I think
ultimately is I think you feel it while
you're watching it I also love the idea
that you are able to give your actors
the opportunity to play because I feel
like the general assumption with
animation is that the animated work is
so difficult to pull off that everything
has to be very rigid and strict to what
those animators create definitely so for
the two of you now getting that wasn't
the experience on this we got to play so
much um yeah Chris was so generous and
with his Direction with um sharing his
you know his amazing imagination is so
infectious um so yeah that that was
definitely the the vibe for this one
lots of playtime this marks your your
first time for both of you voicing an
animated character in a feature film I
feel like maybe the playing around could
answer this question but what would you
say is the biggest misconception you had
about what it would mean to voice an
animated character when you first joined
the project I think for me it it was
definitely I remember my first session
in my head I think sometimes you can
watch animated films and you feel like
oh I need to give it a voice like you
know like like it has to have an iconic
voice now how how do I sound like a cat
and and I remember before I had any
session reading the script and I was
like I'm going to make the the cat sound
like this because you have a visual of
how it looks but you don't realize
you're like this cat has to be me before
it can be someone else so I think it's
it's so important what Chris was saying
about improvisation CU I come from
standup comedy background so I'm so used
to improvising and then Chris said no be
you be yourself and then that just lets
you lets your imagination flow of how
you can make it sound how you can make
it move and walk and talk and stuff as
well just CU that makes me curious when
you first saw like the first rendering
of Becket what did you think he sounded
like before you landed on you know it
being truly you well I think at first
like in my in my head I was like I'm a
cat yeah that's is how I was used to
playing a cat because most cats are
always crafty whe it's like top cat or
you know Tom they're always the they're
always the the kind of ah you know I'm
like Tom is always out to get Jerry top
cat is the coolest cat whereas I was in
a different position where I was I was
trying to be loved at the beginning of
the film and then you then then I I
become loved and then you kind of get
pushed out so it's almost you have to
put your I had to put becket's ego aside
and be like okay I've got to get back
into the good books a little bit so yeah
it was it was a fun challenge really fun
challenge all right Sone I'll go back to
that original question for you now the
biggest misconception you had about what
it was going to take to act in an
animated future it's pretty much the
same like I think I I love voice acting
giving even my own dog a little voice
impersonating like Kermit the Frog or
like Lilo like Stitch from Lilo and
Stitch this is my favorite thing that
pet owners do I know all of my friends
voices for their animals Bas it's we
can't help but personify them I don't
know what it is I'm sure there's some
like weird scientific psychological
reason why we do it but um yeah the
exact same like trying to like create
almost like a cartoon like out you know
out of body kind of voice and then you
you know with with Chris it's so genuine
this this whole movie every every
essence about it and you feel vulnerable
You're So stripped down and it's like
cool it's just my voice and then that
you really focus on is the emotion and
the connection between you know the
friendship with Becka and Rose and the
worlds around them so yeah um I think
that was definitely something that made
this so special and changed my mind
about what it is to to voice act so many
follow-up questions I don't want to
leave the idea of us voicing our pets
for a minute though I'm I'm assuming is
everyone a pet owner here yes yeah what
is the greatest length you've ever gone
to for your pet like something you do
for your pet that is like above and
beyond over the top I think I remember
once my my my dog was ill and and she
kept having bad diarrhea which and at
the time I lived in an apartment and I
remember staying up all night just
watching a dog being like do you need to
go just you need to go and then taking
her down cuz she was still a puppy at
this stage taking her downstairs and it
was probably like 3: in the morning and
being like Oh my God I'm so tired right
now but I understand you're very ill and
you can't talk to me you can't say I've
got a bad stomach so that was the L I
went to yeah good pet parent right there
yeah um my dog's called Mila and um she
went through a phase when she was a
puppy where she just wouldn't eat she
was just so bored of her food and um I
um I made this thing called Mila Moosh
and I would sing a song to her whilst
doing it just to like get her sight for
like dinner time be like oh my God bit
of this bit of that oh and then I
pretend to put it in the oven like time
it it's ready now and like take it out
with my oven gloves and like you know
make this whole thing for her it's the
same it's the same dish but um I'd sing
the Milo Mo song and then it worked and
she was psyched for her meal still get
this so get this have for your
chis well all right
so where my Ruby who was now 6 years old
was a puppy I picked her up from the the
the Breeders and brought home and I was
so in loveed with this St I mean it's
still am don't tell her I said that um
and and I picked this little puppy up
Golden Retriever right big face with a
slightly you know closed eyes and I
kissed her full on the lips no tons but
I would have
done and that's how much I loved her and
uh and and it's been like that ever
since I mean in terms of like just
things you do with your pets and where
you take them and walks and crazy Antics
and both and I have two going rri and
together they were the comedians that
got us through uh the lockdowns really
and it was around here that I was
actually around that time there was Bist
to work on 10 lights so they were
definitely inspiration yeah my folks
have two doxin and they're like kissy
dogs I'm not going to stop them they can
kiss me all they want above and beyond I
have my my Dewey on my wrist for the
rest of my life so very cute with a hat
and everything he he was named after
Deputy Dewey from Scream so that's his
little Deputy hat that's that's my above
and beyond I feel like I had a followup
oh I remember what it was um Simone when
you're doing a performance like this
where you're so hyperfocused on your
voice and your voice alone did that give
you the opportunity to add any tools to
your acting tool kit that you now find
yourself applying to your live action
work wow what a great question um I
think you know the beauty of Animation
is it it it encourages you to really use
your imag use your imagination that
rhymes um and you you know tap into
having faith having hope that this is
real this could happen like really
believing it um believing that you're
there in the booth talking to the cat
talking to the horse all of these
different things and I think um yeah
that's I think something I apply to real
life and apply to my um on like live
action work as well sure we is an
extreme gift because what they not
telling you is that there's no other
actor in the room so
uh all of the emotion of the uh the
sincerity that's coming out it's just
some Lo over zoom in California say well
that's what if and I mean again not
everybody can do this these guys are it
and the that life that that that fun in
every syllable comes through in the
movie and a b up with SS a little bit
Yeah I Chris I I I just kept and Chris
at the beginning of this like I can sing
I'd love to sing in this I've written
some songs mulele none of my songs like
it was all Zayn like Zayn's music Z
soundtrack is just beautiful in this but
um Chris was so generous and said would
you like to sing this song and do a du
at with zaye and yeah it made my year
was one of the best experiences ever
that was such a beautiful sweet thing to
add now I'm going to make it awkward
because I'm fascinated by efforts when
you're voice acting can you each
pinpoint you know an effort that came
naturally to you but then also want the
opposite like an everyday sound that's
just really difficult to replicate
believably in the sound booth I think my
one of my second sessions was pretending
to climb through a drain pipe as as a
rat and it was the most in your head
you're like this is easy just pretend to
climb and and you're like hold on
no and it cuz it had to break and then I
had to squeeze again and when you do it
the first time you're like that's
probably it and it's like you do it
again but imagine this time you're
really stuck and then and then uh it's
like okay cool and then an eagle's going
to take you and you have to imagine I
was literally I'm very physical so I'd
be like imagine I've being taken by an
eagle and um it pushes you as a range
because again this is very new for me
but trying to I think when you you know
when you're able to say the lines and
you can be funny and articulate yourself
is is quite easy but when you have to do
all the intro cut stuff and you know be
your horse and you you know you have to
imagine that you're smashing up um
someone's kind of laboratory is quite
difficult to do and imagine you get to
see it but you're like okay cool how
would I sound if I if I fell you know so
um I think that that breathing
that was yeah that was hard it's a good
example Fair example right there what do
you got I think I think Mo had like one
of the hardest jobs I think really
bringing a cat to life so I think for
Rose you you know she she she is like
our our young modern day woman heroine
in this movie um so I guess some of it
it was just actually not making it so
difficult and just believing it and like
something as natural as like not
overthinking it um I think that because
I think it's natural to overthink
something like that when you're in the
booth and like you're cut off from all
the other senses and it's just your
voice um I think I'd love to do
something similar to Becket one day like
really do like an animal or something a
bit more Larger than Life like a cartoy
kind of animal one day I get my notebook
out work yeah yeah well I mean I feel
like uh is there like is there a
different department for different
animals and it could just become an
anthology where yeah like different
animals go go up and come back and do it
all over again a lot of room to exp yet
even humans even humans I have to end
with our uh filmio specific question
because as I mentioned up top the
company is all about putting the
creative power in the artist's hand and
also the fans hands as well so for each
of you whether it was on this project or
something else you've done can you give
me an example of a time when someone
else gave you the creative power maybe a
time when you know you thought you
deserved it but you didn't expect to get
it well for me it would be on this film
I again I didn't have any perceived
notion of how I approach this and you
know Chris was just like be yourself do
you and he wanted me to be me like
almost as much as me as possible in this
film from having little anecdotes the
way that I speak the way that I speak
naturally and where I'm from on my
background and I was able to put that in
the cat and I think that was what I
enjoyed so much took me out my comfort
zone but also it was a challenge there's
times where I'd say something and look
at chrism like yeah he like it that's
cool like so that that's probably mine
my my one yeah good example right there
um I guess definitely on this project I
think you know I think all artists like
directors actors whatever you're doing
in the world of film or music whatever
it is you it's understanding you you
have the right to have creative input
like it's you it's your work like so I I
I guess that's why I would say to any
young um aspiring artists listening
watching this that you it's your right
like it's your it's your craft so yeah
you have creative input should always be
that simple yeah yeah how about for you
Chris
there was an old fell he was in his 90s
in bash of
Disney Joe Grant and Fe Dumbo the most
of and this guy was such he was a gentle
man he's a
gentleman and uh I got close to him in
in the last couple of years of his life
actually he showed me all of the
references that he' collected over the
years so you can do this and it took me
from where I was as an animator into
another part of the of making
movies I'll always remember that it's
great
guy such a beautiful example thank you
for sharing that and thank you to all
three of you for being here and talking
10 lives with us thank you to everybody
out there 10 lives don't miss it a must
SE for animal lovers obviously but
really anybody who wants to walk out of
a movie with a full heart so check it
out and we'll be back soon with more
interviews at Sundance